s'il ya du trafic même le dimanche c'est
que la rue hippolyte foucque permet de
traverser saint joseph sans passer par
le centre ville c'est aussi et surtout
parce qu'on y trouve un collège un lycée
et de nombreux jeunes y aurait-il donc
un lien entre ces établissements et
hippolyte foucque
est ce que vous savez qui ati politique
ou canon hulala après fait ça annonce
était il pense qu'il ya fait les lycées
n'ont que peu et quelques instants
administration biaggi peut-être à vous
redresser aux noms professions des
écoles quelque chose comme ça jetons
rage aux réactions dans les milieux
enseignant science chez plus maintenant
mari victor hippolyte foucque est né le
15 mars 1987 à sainte marie il perd son
père directeur de l' usine de la mort à
l'âge de cinq ans après son baccalauréat
en 1904 il poursuit des études de
lettres à la sorbonne
agrégé hippolyte foucque est affecté au
lycée de moulins dans l'allier en 1913
un an plus tard retour au pays pour
enseigner au lycée leconte de lisle
mais à peine at il eu le temps de s'y
intégrer qu'il est envoyé à madagascar
au sein d'une colonne de secours pour
l'afrique orientale pour cause de grande
guerre de longues années s'écoulent
alors avant le vrai départ à la guerre
en grèce et salonique en 1917 il
retrouve son poste au lycée son mariage
en 1919 quelques jours après la fin de
l'épidémie de grippe espagnole lancre
définitivement dans son île
en 1930 le voilà promu proviseur du
lycée leconte de lisle et chef du
service de l'instruction publique à la
départementalisation il est nommé
inspecteur d'académie et occupe le poste
de vice-recteur retraités à 67 ans il
prend la rédaction en chef du journal le
peuple en 1963 on lui propose de supplée
la candidature de michel debré à la
députation mais il refuse trop vieux
juge-t-il
il a 76 ans il préfère continuer ses
chroniques radio sous le pseudonyme de
grand-père onésime et comment hippolyte
foucque mort le 1er août 1970 à saint
denis
il repose dans le cimetière de sa ville
natale